hi everyone in this video I'll be
talking about bacterial artificial
chromosomes now bacterial artificial
chromosome in contrast to plasmids are
having bigger carrying capacity or a
higher carrying capacity so the carrying
capacity that means the the size of the
fragment or the gene of interest it can
carry is kind of 100 KB to 300 KB which
is huge because plasmids carrying
capacity is less than 10 KB I mean if
there is anything which is more than 10
KB is cloning the plasmid the plasmid
would not propagate properly so in that
respect bacterial artificial chromosomes
are specially designed for cloning very
big DNA fragments like an entire genome
of virus now let's just quickly go over
to all the features of the back like any
cloning vectors back should also have a
multiple cloning site which would have a
scribble marker for example here in
yellow the screen will marker is Lac C
will come in a moment how this crinimal
marker work but before that there are
other sites important features of the
back-to-back vector so the antibiotic
resistance which would work like a
selectable marker which would allow us
to understand that the bacteria I mean
allow us to ensure that the bacteria
only if take up this back plasmid would
grow or otherwise it won't grow because
we would grow the bacteria in a
antibiotic candy containing solution
only the antibiotic resistance gene can
allow the bacteria to grow so that allow
us to get rid of those plasma mean those
bacterias which has not taken any plasma
to die eventually now for proper
segregation of the plasmid or proper
replication of the plasmid there is a
origin of replication site and there is
a F plasmid per gene and this part gene
is specifically important for segregates
it's known as partition gene it is
important for segregation of the
bacterial artificial chromosome we'll
talk about it later now let's try to
understand that how these screw noble
marker work so the legs II generally
produce a Pyrrhic electricity's enzyme
now beta collector series enzyme can
cleave xkl which would
a colored compound now for example if
the bacteria I mean if the bacteria is
only getting a plasmid where the lagg-3
portion is intact
then it would create the egg scale it
will cleave the egg scale and create a
blue colored colony and blue cone colony
would tell us the bacteria doesn't have
any recombinant plasmid in contrast if
the lagg-3 gene is disrupted by the
become the DNA of interest that we want
to clone then it would be disrupted and
as a result it won't produce video
galactosidase and when we transmit into
the bacteria it won't produce
beta-galactosidase so the colonies would
not be blue it would be white so
depending upon the white or blue
colonies we can understand that which
colony contains bacteria that has the
recombinant construct because sometimes
what happens is like there is self
ligation so in order to get rid of self
ligated plasmid in the bacteria we can
use this kind of screen able marker and
similarly these kinds this kind of
scribble marker which works in the
principle of insertional inactivation
could be used in plasmids as well now in
case of backs it is little bit difficult
to get the cloned plasmid into the
bacteria because backs are huge imagine
like there is 100 to 300 KB of DNA
insert into the back so they are very
big so how you can get the backs inside
is by electroporation the normal method
of hit shock transformation want to work
in case of back so you can electro put
it and using the using the help of
electrical force you can get the plasmid
inside with higher efficiency now once
the plasmid is inside the back and you
give proper temperature for the
bacterias to grow the bacteria would
grow in number but wait a minute
the problem with backs is they're like
so big now if you don't have some
methods by which you can ensure that the
bacteria would like equally segregate
the back in each generation then there
is a problem in order to ensure that the
backs are segregated properly in each
generation when the bacteria is growing
there is the F plasmid per gene the F
plasmid perching ensures there is an
even distribution of the bacterial
artificial chromosome now packs are
always used for large-scale genome
sequencing for example backs are used in
human genome sequencing project as well
and here are some overall usage of back
or backlight cloning vectors first they
are used for a large-scale human genome
sequencing project etc they could be
also used to clone the whole genome of a
virus like pox virus herpes virus and
corona virus you can create infectious
colonies that could be used for several
other research purposes as well now
let's say a disease related gene which
is a big gene can be even clone and it
can be used to make a transgenic animal
like a transgenic Mouse and back would
be a useful vector in that respect now
back has a problem as well like that has
the huge advantage because of its
carrying capacity is huge but its
problem is it's like difficult to
transform and it's low copy number now
it's difficult to transform that can be
overcome by the electroporation method
rather than the normal transfection
method transformation method now the low
copy number can also be taken care of by
putting a second extra origin of
replication v site now this auravie site
would generate multiple copies of Beck's
if a transacting factor known as TR F is
transfer glory factor is present so it
would ensure the copy number of the
bacterial artificial chromosome is
maintained so in that way you can have
you can overcome the existing problem of
the bacterial artificial chromosome so
if you liked my video give it a quick
thumbs up and don't forget to Like share
and subscribe thank you